[Applaudissements]
mon père qu'est ce que tu penses démarre
son salaire la sécu on en est où papa
dix mois a suivi l'émission oui mais non
mais vas-y moi ça c'est qu est ce que tu
trouves pas le chiffre vraiment
exorbitants et total à la mi temps je
pense que le club devrait payer les
opérations de des grands joueurs de foot
avec un salaire pareil le problème c'est
que je ne sais pas ce qu on fait juste
après c'est quoi la séquence que je ne
vais pas beaucoup
[Rires]
on va faire danser la dernière image
la dernière image donc c'est la dernière
image voilà regardez-moi la galette
dernières infos
c'est un piège regardez cette photo
c'est un piège et une photo s'affiche
c'est un boulevard qui revient comme ça
je suis gentil je vous voyez vous met à
l'aise
la photo juste derrière est un piège de
quoi on parle avec cette image des amis
on peut bien pouvoir parler titoff amis
à l'idée géniale et des minimes de laura
smet qui va peut-être je sais pas enfin
parler qui va quoi enfin parler enfin
parler c'est pas mal mon père un petit
une petite idée sur le sujet ah oui bah
oui parce que les prix devraient
présenter des missions justement faire
bien plus en reste elle pense qu'il
était question que laura smet fasse une
apparition ce soir aux césar exact voilà
et on parle d'elle parce qu'elle est je
crois un détournement d'une pub pas très
pas très pas très maligne me semble-t-il
sur une bien sous l'information s'est
passé après six années passées aux taxis
c'est quoi alors d'après tu affiches
d'après tu affiches laura smet donc est
donc apparemment va donc remettre un
césar et elles et elles devraient être
présentes à la cérémonie des césar qui a
lieu donc ce vendredi soir bon elle va
donc monter sur scène et faire une
petite récompense qui est donc le césar
commerce ingénieurs et des parterres
tel père tel fils que la mer
[Applaudissements]